bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 60,18 bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez voici les titres de ce
lundi 7 septembre alors que le
département est toujours classé en zone
de circulation active du coronavirus un
grand dépistage a débuté aujourd'hui au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il va durer
jusqu'à mercredi et s'adresse aux
salariés des entreprises est l'occasion
de faire le point sur l'épidémie avec l'
agence régionale de santé le match
caritatif du variétés club de france à
poissy d'anciennes stars du football se
sont mobilisés hier pour les hôpitaux
rencontre face à une équipe de soignants
du centre hospitalier
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye et le
public était au rendez vous au stade léo
lagrange
et puis notre page dédiée aux élections
législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines premier
tour dimanche 20 septembre
ils sont onze sur la ligne de départ
parmi eux patrick planque en lice pour
lutte ouvrière et nous parlerons
également de cette opération vendredi au
lycée dumont-d'urville à maurepas une
opération de ramassage des déchets opéré
par les lycéens c'est à la fin de ce
journal
le vélodrome de national de saint
quentin en yvelines est donc devenu
depuis ce matin un centre de dépistage
au kovy 19 et ce pendant trois jours
l'opération est destinée exclusivement
aux salariés objectifs espérés
plus de 2000 personnes testées ont fait
le point avec michael et demi d'euros
c'est une opération inédite en france
pendant trois jours les salariés des
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
peuvent se faire dépister de lakovic 19
au vélodrome nationale le dispositif est
gratuit et anonyme et durera jusqu'au 9
septembre en partenariat avec la rs on a
commencé cette idée dès le mois de mars
on l'a proposé à rs mais à ce moment là
les tests n'étaient pas disponibles donc
aujourd'hui le sont donc dès qu'ils ont
eu le nombre bien sûr adéquate à un
vélodrome et à saint quentin
ils nous ont rappelés ils nous ont
demandé si notre proposition était
toujours à l'âme
on leur dit bien bien entendu on la fait
bien sûr dans l'est dans les dix jours
qui ont suivi donc pour aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir accueillir les employés
l'enceinte sportive s'est transformé un
accueil a été mise en place en centre
pistes et des tentes ont été montées les
gens qui sont malades ne seront pas
testés assez rapidement parce qu'ils
sont dans la même file d'attenté
habituellement que les gens qui ne sont
pas malades ici c'est différent il ya
une file d'attende pour les gens qui
sont malades et ça c'est vraiment
nouveau c'est spécifique à cet endroit
j'ai jamais vu ailleurs et puis à la
file d'attenté pour les gens qui ne sont
pas malades et qui veulent se faire
tester ce matin dès les premières heures
des dizaines de salariés sont venus se
faire tester dans un créneau communiquer
en amont par la rs france est une
responsabilité collective
on sait qu'il ya des cas symptomatiques
donc c'est notre responsabilité de faire
tester on a la chance d'avoir une
entreprise qui nous permet de nous faire
tester facilement sans avoir à faire la
file d'attende dans un laboratoire n'a
on est arrivés aucune attente donc c'est
parfait
j'ai pas de symptômes mais voilà je vais
savoir comme je vais retourner
travailler en entreprise et je voulais
être sûr de ne pas reprendre vis-à-vis
de mes collègues et puis et puis aussi
d'aider mes amis au total l'opération
devrait permettre de réaliser plus de
2000 tests pcr pendant les trois jours
et pour parler de l'épidémie de kobe de
19 je suis avec marion de chine ali en
visio bonsoir vous êtes la directrice de
la délégation départementale des
yvelines de la rs ile-de-france les rs
et bien sûr l'agencé régionale de santé
dimanche plus de 7000 cas positifs ont
été enregistrés en 24 heures en france
est ce que les indicateurs sont aussi
inquiétants en région ile de france et
dans le département des yvelines alors
la région ile de france est classée
rouge depuis maintenant jouer pour les
yvelines le seuil les seuils d'alert à
la fois sur les taux d'incidence et les
taux de positivité ont été dépassées il
ya maintenant dix jours effectivement
donc on est également classée rouge ce
qui prouve qu'ils aimeraient circulation
du virus circulation du virus est ce que
on a aussi des statistiques inquiétantes
du côté des hôpitaux est ce qui a
davantage d'entrée à l'hôpital de
patients qui sont placées en réanimation
non alors au niveau de l'hôpital on voit
pour vous pas du tout la même chose
qu'au mois de mars il ya une progression
qui est lente et continue depuis
maintenant la mini le milieu de l'été
mais par contre c'est une scission et
j'ai une situation qui reste
complètement gérable et géré par les
hôpitaux on est vraiment sûr
effectivement une circulation du virus
avec des cas qui sont moins graves pour
ce qu'on a comme on sait la stratégie
c'est dépistés à grande échelle c'est le
cas sur ces trois jours au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines ou
trois mille tests pcr seront réalisés
c'est en tout cas un objectif affiché
est ce que de nombreux dépistage ont
déjà pu avoir lieu dans les deviner ce
que d'autres sont prévues dans les
prochains jours
on a perdu peut-être la connexion avec
mario jean a lille vous nous entendez
toujours moyen de chine ali on a perdu
la connexion centre a peut-être la
retrouver vous nous entendez peut-être
mario de finale il vous est toujours
avec nous la connexion a visiblement été
perdu merci à vous en tout cas mario
jean ali d'avoir été avec non tentera
peut-être de vous rejoindre
au cours de ce journal je rappelle que
vous êtes la directrice de la délégation
départementale des yvelines pour la rs
santé toujours avec la ville de maurepas
qui est désormais c'est une nouveauté
conventionnés avec l'établissement
français du sang que changent
concrètement ce partenariat
éléments de réponse avec célia agathe
son go et patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est dans la salle des fêtes à paris
ouest amoureux pas que s'est tenue la
première collecte de dons du sang
conventionnés avec le f s
depuis le 30 juin 2020 la ville est
désormais une commune partenaire du don
du sang ce qui amène à quelques
changements et facilite une meilleure
prise en charge des donneurs nous
mettons à disposition une salle qui est
qui est en accord avec les besoins des
deux le ffs est une mise à disposition
gracieuse bien évidemment et on part
elle de sa charge à nous de communiquer
sur les dates sur le lieu est de faire
un peu de la publicité si j'ose dire
pour que y ait un maximum de
deux heures qui viennent avant les
professionnels de l'établissement
français du sang était reçu dans un
camion et accueillait environ une
trentaine de donneurs ce jour-là 90
personnes sont venues faire un don ce
partenariat permet aussi à le fs de se
déplacer davantage sur le territoire
ighli noah c'est aussi la garantie de
pouvoir avoir des portes ouvertes et
pouvoir être là aussi fréquemment que la
population voudra bien tenir trois
autres dates de collecte sont déjà
prévues à mon repas pour l'année 2020
aussi qu'on trouve le jour faut qu'on
trouve le rite faut qu on habitue les
gens à venir et revenir parce que bien
sûr qu'il ait lu covin bien sûr qui à la
rentrée il ya eu un été qui a été
difficile mais en fait c'est tous les
jours dont on a besoin des produits
sanguins en ile-de-france 1700 dons sont
nécessaires chaque jour pour répondre
aux besoins des malades
l'on a retrouvé la connexion avec mario
jean ali directrice de la délégation
départementale des yvelines de la rs
pour parler encore de l'épidémie de kobe
19 j'avais juste une dernière question
maria chin ali on sait que la stratégie
pour lutter contre la propagation du
virus est de dépister à grande échelle
est ce que de nombreux dépistage sont
encore ont pu avoir lieu déjà dans les
yvelines est ce que deux prochains sont
prévues visiblement la connexion qui a
du mal aujourd'hui sur ce journal c'est
pas grave marion qui allie encore merci
d'avoir été avec nous et je rappelle que
êtes la directrice de la délégation
départementale de la rs la connexion est
visiblement perdu dans l'actualité
aussi le département des yvelines pleure
l'un de ses enfants le hussard
parachutiste de 1ère classe
arnaud volpe est l'un des deux soldats
français tués samedi dans le nord du
mali victime d'un engin explosif
artisanal lors d'une opération dans la
région de tessalit tu le militaire née
en 1996 à versailles et résidait avec
ses parents aux essarts-le-roi un
hommage lui était rendu d'ailleurs par
le maire de la commune et aussi par la
ministre des armées florence parly
arnaud volpe avait 24 ans florence parly
qui s'est rendu en fin de semaine
dernière au lycée militaire de saint cyr
l'école une année particulière s'annonce
pour l'établissement avec un nouveau nom
et des travaux de rénovation justin
brasier
la ministre des armées florence parly
s'est rendu au lycée militaire de saint
cyr l'école
objectif de la rencontre faire un point
sur les investissements pour
l'établissement mais aussi sur cette
rentrée si particulière c'est année
particulière parce que l'environnement
sanitaire est fragile mais le lycée
militaire a tout mis en oeuvre pour
accueillir ses élèves
tout est mis en oeuvre au niveau
sanitaire je parle bien sûr du port du
masque obligatoire au quotidien la
ministre des armées a profité de sa
visite pour annoncer officiellement le
nouveau nom de l'établissement il
s'appellera désormais lycée militaire de
gaulle de saint cyr l'école
nous avons pensé que c'était le bon
moment pour que le lycée de saint cyr
l'école porte aussi le nom du général de
gaulle et c'est donc en accord avec le
chef d'état major de l'armée de terre
que nous avons annoncé cet après midi
que le lycée militaire s'appellerait
lycée militaire de gaulle de saint cyr
l'école
autre nouveauté les 22 millions d'euros
d'investissements prévus à saint cyr
l'école
un projet qui s'inscrit dans le cadre du
plan lycée objectif rénover les locaux
devenus vétustes et un bâtiment
modulaire qui actuellement est en
construction qui accueillera sur les
deux années à venir
les classes préparatoires le temps que
leur bâtiment soit rénové et ainsi à la
fin de cette rénovation
ce bâtiment sera transformé en salle de
cours le premier investissement qui est
ici qui sera occupé dès qu'il sera
terminé c'est-à-dire mois de janvier
2021 et ensuite des travaux démarreront
dans les bâtiments qui le nécessitent
le bâtiment l'as salé et ensuite le
bâtiment tom morel au total ce sont près
de 800 élèves qui ont fait leur rentrée
au lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
début septembre
[Musique]
autre déplacement ce matin à trappes
philippe benassaya s'est rendu à
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien en
compagnie de philippe juvin maire de la
garenne colombes et chef des urgences de
l'hôpital pompidou à paris une visite
pour le maire de bois d'arcy dans le
cadre de la campagne pour l'élection
législative partielle dans la 11e
circonscription philippe benassaya le
candidat du parti les républicains
déplacements autour de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire par des élus locaux les
propos sont accueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude la crise n'est pas
terminée il faut être sur le terrain
pour voir comment ça se passe et
l'hôpital de trappes et un hôpital
symbolique sur notre territoire qui
irrigue les villes qui sont autour de
trappes et je me devais d'être là avec
le philippe juvin le médecin bien connue
au niveau national pour faire le tour un
petit peu des hôpitaux et notamment
celui de trappes pour savoir comment ça
se passe et comment
comment on gère cette crise sanitaire
au quotidien un déplacement qui s'est
poursuivie au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à l'occasion
du dépistage géant dont nous vous
parlions en début de journal ils sont
d'ailleurs 11 11
en course dans cette 11e circonscription
des yvelines vous voyez leurs mots
s'afficher premier tour le dimanche 20
septembre une élection rendue nécessaire
pour rappel après la démission de nadia
est devenu ministre délégué à la ville
dans le nouveau gouvernement
et parmi les candidats l'un d'entre eux
est avec moi patrick planque mon soir
vous êtes cheminots brienne maintenance
à la sncf à la gare de triage de trappes
vous êtes candidat de lutte ouvrière
dans cette 11e circonscription vous
l'étiez déjà comme suppléant en 2017 est
derrière à christine et gace là c'est
elle qui est votre suppléante et vous
avez obtenu 3 % lors des élections
municipales à trappes où vous étiez
également candidat en mars dernier
pourquoi cette nouvelle candidature
pourquoi finalement continuer votre
engagement qui n'est pas nouveau du coup
là parce que de toute façon les
problèmes restent les mêmes la situation
pour les travailleurs elle s'est même
aggravée avec la sig la crise économique
la crise du coc vide et on est très loin
de trouver les solutions pour les
travailleurs aujourd'hui et donc notre
candidature puisqu'il y en a d'autres
dans d'autres circonscriptions elles
sont tout à fait justifiées faire
entendre la voix des travailleurs c'est
l'objectif de notre candidature et vous
le disais c'est d'autant plus important
est que le contexte de crise sanitaire
qui s'est muée en crise économique avec
des chiffres du chômage qui ne sont pas
bons là c'est quand même oui les
chiffres du chômage sont catastrophiques
et ils vont encore être catastrophique
ils vont continuer et c'est loin d'être
suffisant le plan de relance que le
gouvernement a proposé ces dernières
semaines 100 milliards distribués à
fonds perdus aux entreprises
c'est inadmissible dans le sens où les
grandes entreprises qui vont bénéficier
de cette aide de ces aides publiques
ils vont continuer à faire des plans de
licenciements continuer à faire des
plans de suppressions d'emplois et oasis
tu pour puisqu'on parle du chômage parce
qu'il faut les mettre là en face de
l'autre
100 milliards ces 2,7 millions
d'emploi qu'on pourrait créer
directement à 1800 euros net par mois
c'est là la solution réellement pour
pour si on veut régler le problème du
chômage si on veut régler le problème de
la répartition du travail entre tous et
c'est ça se peut être être une mesure à
porter à l'assemblée nationale quels
sont les autres je crois que parmi les
propositions celle d'interdire les
licenciements notamment bien sûr parce
que quand on voit aujourd'hui aussi bien
les boîtes de l'aéronautique airbus
thales pour palais pour pas les nommer
nokia et nokia et alinéa
bien sûr qu'on est scandalisé par par
ces plans de licenciement par veille bon
voilà ces grands groupes qui ont fait
des bénéfices depuis des années des
années depuis des dizaines d'années qui
ont engrangé des fortunes colossales et
qui aujourd'hui sous prétexte de
difficultés pas avérée font pression sur
les travailleurs licenciés etc
oui ça c'est inadmissible j'imagine
qu'il ya aussi un intérêt particulier
avec cette rentrée à l'assemblée
nationale un sujet qui va revenir sur la
table celui de la réforme des retraites
qui avait été repoussée ça c'est aussi
un dossier que qui est suivi avec
attention vous êtes contre cette réforme
des retraites ah bah oui aujourd'hui en
tant qu' en tant que cheminot de toute
façon jamais battu suppression des
régimes spéciaux voilà c'est ça on l'a
on l'a largement combattue au début
d'année et on sera encore dans la rue
pour continuer parce qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui la vraie solution ce serait
réellement de répartir le travail entre
tous c'est complètement aberrant de voir
dans les ateliers dans les usines les
gens qui crèvent au boulot ceux qui ont
un travail et épis à côté à côté de ça
on laisse des dizaines des centaines de
milliers de gens des millions de gens
sans travail sans rien
j'ai été alors que alors que bien sûr
qu'il ya du boulot dans les hôpitaux
dans les écoles
aujourd'hui il faudra embaucher
massivement sur cette thématique de
l'emploi si on voit plus large en termes
de politique de la ville c'est une
circonscription qui est totalement
dédiée à cette politique de la ville il
faut il faut faire davantage
aujourd'hui j'ai pas de ces pas de davie
en tout cas sur une politique de la
ville particulière comme moi y est les
quelques mois de l'exercice de nadia
dans cette circonscription
le problème c'est que c'est comme ce
qu'on a pu dire aux municipales c'est de
toute façon il peut pas y avoir un
paradis il peut pas y avoir une
circonscription où un îlot de de
bien-être pour les travailleurs pour les
salariés dans un monde où la crise et
est roi est bon et il vrai problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'effectivement les
travailleurs ne prennent pas conscience
et c'est ça le sens de ma candidature
c'est aussi de de dd à ce qu'ils
prennent conscience dans leur force
collective à la fois pour remplacer pour
remplacer la bourgeoisie à la tête de la
société parce qu'effectivement il faudra
se poser le problème de remplacer cette
classe capitaliste qui nous mène à la
ruine aussi bien aussi bien en france
que dans le reste du monde un dernier
mot sur votre campagne on vous avez
suivi lors d'une opération sur le marché
de trappes c'est pas trop difficile en
ce moment avec ce contexte sanitaire
d'aller à la rencontre des électeurs
bah vous paradoxalement non les gens
sont plutôt contents de nous voir
content de ce qu'on peut raconter
on a retrouvé des tas de gens qu'on
avait rencontré pendant la campagne des
municipales
d'ailleurs on va on va continuer à les
réunir ont fait un meeting
enfin une réunion publique par un
meeting mais en tout cas une réunion
publique le vendredi 18 à trappes à la
maison des familles oui et tous les gens
qui qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui sur les
marchés ou dans les halls d'immeubles
sont très contents de nous voir et
discuter de la situation
merci patrick planque je rappelle que
vous êtes le candidat de lutte ouvrière
pour cette législative partielle dans la
12e circonscription des yvelines
le sport à présent avec ses grands noms
du football français arsène wenger
christian karembeu alain giresse ou
encore laurent blanc tous se
retrouvaient hier à l'occasion d'un
match caritatif à poissy le variétés
club de france et jouets au profit de la
fondation des hôpitaux de france et face
aux anciennes gloires du ballon rond une
équipe de soignants en retour sur cette
rencontre avec patrick jacques de
dixmude et mélanie poker les stars du
jour c'était le personnel du centre
hospitalier intercommunal de poissy
saint germain en laye des soignants
accueilli sous les applaudissements pour
ce nouveau match du variétés club de
france
retrouvailles avec les administrés
retrouvailles avec les copains du s'agit
poissy j'ai une licence avec lui depuis
25 ans maintenant c'est formidable ce
qu'ils ont fait pendant ce mobile et
puis retrouvailles avec avec toutes les
stars du variétés n'a aucun enjeu
sportif
le seul enjeu qui y est c'est le plaisir
surpris mais c'est le plaisir du coeur
une trentaine d'anciens footballeurs
professionnels a répondu à l'invitation
de jacques vendroux le manager du vin il
était parmi eux plusieurs membres de
l'équipe étoilée 2998 c'est un sujet qui
nous tient à coeur et voilà la grande
famille du football s'est réuni et
évidemment le personnel hospitalier
aussi et on se doit de faire cet effort
là pour ceux qui nous en garantie des
vies sauvées des vies et qui continue à
essayer de celui des lycéens plaisir
parce que bon ils ont été soumis à rude
à rude épreuve
durant sept heures cette crise sanitaire
et c'est aussi pour eux qu'un jour là on
joue pas pour nous on joue pour les
autres donc c'est vraiment ça à l'idée
face à de grands noms on en vient même à
faire la fine bouche quand on tousse
cover j'aurais bien oui c'est arsène
wenger va tracer le coach que j'ai
toujours aimé étant jeune pour la petite
histoire c'est la variété qui remporte
le match
score final 4 buts à 1 et puisqu'on
parle de football bravo 9 club yvelinois
qui se sont qualifiés hier pour le
deuxième tour de la coupe de france pour
terminer un green day au lycée les
élèves de dumont d'urville à maurepas se
sont mobilisés vendredi pour
l'environnement pendant une matinée ils
ont ramassé les déchets autour de leur
établissement une action loin d'être
unique sur place bixente maria senti
steban et nicolas landry 120 kg de
déchets c'est le bilan de la matinée
réalisés par les élèves du lycée dumont
d'urville
pour cette activité ils étaient une
centaine divisés en plusieurs groupes
objectif couvrir un maximum de terrain
détritus trouvés n'ont d'ailleurs pas
sûr que les étudiants les masques des
mégots des bouteilles de verre des
canettes des bouteilles de plastique
c'est des choses un peu auquel on
s'attendait heureusement en fait on
s'est réuni entre éco délégués pour
organiser cet événement est motivé le
plus de lycéens possible afin de leur
faire prendre conscience
la dégradation qui est fait par tous les
fers de lance de cette action sont les
éco-délégués mise en place pour la
deuxième année consécutive ils sont une
quinzaine d'élèves volontaires agir en
faveur du développement durable
c'était la première année que s'était
mis en place c'était notamment de faire
de la sensibilisation sur le
développement durable pour que les
élèves sachent de pouce que c'est en
fait en première main du coup commencé
les actions concrètes telles que le
recyclage du papier dans les classes
également montrer la quantité de pain
gaspillés chaque semaine à la cantine la
sensibilité à l'environnement est de
rigueur au lycée dumont d'urville
les élèves sont concernés et pilotes
eux-mêmes leurs actions cela fait déjà
pratiquement un an et demi que
qu'ils réfléchissent à des solutions au
niveau local pour changer finalement
notre façon d'appréhender
l'environnement le monde dans lequel ils
vivent
d'autres actions sont en cours de
réflexion entre les éco délégués du
lycée avec cet objectif de poursuivre la
sensibilisation sur le développement
durable c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]